Hello everyone, I hope that you're good.
What's going on with Bitcoin? It's not
moving.
We're still in this range. We came to
test the range lows again. But really,
it's not moving, okay? It's quite stable
at the moment. This is the 1-hour time
frame, you can see.
It's not moving, guys, you know? Okay,
we're ranging here between 30k and
29,600, you could say, okay? So, we're
in this zone.
Okay? But nothing is really happening.
Now, some people might say that we are
in a, you know, in a downtrend in
smaller time frame. Others might say
that, you know, this is maybe like an
inverse head and shoulders, okay? And
now price is going to go higher. But
you guys know that I don't look for a
fixed pattern, so
what I want to try to understand what is
going on here, okay? The first thing is
that if we go into the 1-hour 50 MA,
we kind of still see, you know, that
we're testing the 50 MA so many times as
resistance, okay? All the time here.
Again, all the time here. Uh last night
we saw a fake out, okay? Here. It seemed
like we were holding above the daily
Sorry, the 1-hour 50 MA.
But then we fell again, okay?
So, you can see
that the 1-hour 50 MA
keeps pushing us lower.
But at some point, I'll tell you, when
there is a very clear resistance like
this, okay? Price, sooner or later, is
going to make the attempt of pushing
higher,
uh retesting the support, and continue
higher, okay?
Now, we can find some confluence for
this idea. Uh basically, I'm telling you
that
uh what I was telling you yesterday, um
I still think that that's more likely to
happen, okay?
Uh I mean, yesterday we saw some kind of
a short squeeze, but I don't think
that's enough because you can see that
price hasn't really broken out of this
zone. Uh now, if we go into the dollar
index,
okay? You're going to notice that the
dollar index is printing here a W
formation, okay?
Uh
this it's quite interesting because you
can see that we've been in the dollar
index has been pumping. But
if we go back to Bitcoin
it's, you know
it's holding here.
So, that's showing some kind of strength
for Bitcoin. Otherwise, you know, dollar
going up Bitcoin should going down.
Okay? And that's not what is going on,
okay? Let's go back to the dollar index.
Let's talk about the dollar index.
So, you go here the dollar index.
Sorry. There you go.
Printing this W formation, of course,
it's going to find some resistance here
in this zone.
Let me check it for you. But in this
zone there should be some resistance.
Also, if you go into the 4-hour time
frame, I think that we have here the
4-hour 50 MA. There you go, okay? That's
going to be another resistance. And of
course, this orange line, if you go into
higher time frame, daily time frame, you
can see that that should be
quite a big resistance. Now, we were
talking here
when we were in this zone
about the idea of
pushing lower. Okay?
This is a three tops pattern. One top,
two tops. And we were talking about the
idea of a third top with a deviation,
okay? Now, I didn't think that was going
to go this low. But it could still be a
big deviation if it gets confirmed,
okay?
If it's a deviation
of course, it needs to get back inside
this orange line test it as a support
and then go higher. Now, if this happens
here
okay? If we get to this point you know,
I can tell you that this point the
dollar index should go higher and
Bitcoin should go lower. And that's
when, for example, you would, you know,
you could see Bitcoin breaking out to
the downside of that range. But
so far that's not happening, okay? We
are still here. If you go into the
4-hour time frame
uh this is the 50 MA. And I was telling
you
if the dollar index wants to go lower
and this is truly bearish and it's not a
deviation, okay?
And it just wants to go lower, then
don't expect the dollar index
to retest this orange level over here,
okay? Cuz it shouldn't get there if this
is really bearish, okay? If this is so
bearish
it should probably, you know, come as
high
as this yellow line or the 4 or 50-day
somewhere like this, okay? Make a move
here and then drop.
Okay?
That's if the dollar index is bearish.
Otherwise if you start to see the dollar
index, you know moving here, test this
zone as support, you know, another push
higher, then it can consolidate above
this zone.
This when you can expect the dollar
index to have a very aggressive move up.
Okay?
Um, I'll tell you. I still I still
uh, can't dismiss the idea that this is
a deviation, okay? As long as I don't
see another, you know, leg lower. Sorry,
lower, okay? And
a new low.
Okay? When that happens, I'll tell you,
"Yeah, okay, that's that wasn't a
deviation. The dollar index is going to
continue going lower, okay?" But for now
something tells me that this is a very
psychological number, 100.
Okay? Make a deviation at 99 exactly.
And then reverse, okay?
It would be quite a psychological game,
but, you know, it would make sense.
Now, based on this idea of the dollar
index, I was already looking at this
since yesterday. Now, if you go into the
euro dollar pair, let's get there, okay?
You're going to be able to see
the euro was, you know
mhm, well, it did a very nice move up
here.
Okay? And then here, you can see a lot
of wicks to the upside, but price
couldn't break higher. So then you know,
this plus the idea of the dollar index
forming that W formation, you would
expect the euro versus the dollar going
to retest the 4-hour 50 MA.
Okay? And I think that's what is
currently going on here. Now, you guys
know that most of the time I'm trading
cryptocurrency, especially Bitcoin,
because that's the asset that I feel
uh most comfortable trading with, okay?
Sometimes I trade altcoins at at the
weekend,
but that's not that often, okay? Only if
I see a very high probability setup at
the weekend developing in altcoins. And
on the weekdays,
today's the best example, okay? You have
Bitcoin doing nothing. You have Bitcoin,
you know, moving sideways. But if you go
into Forex, you can see the dollar
index, you know, forming a beautiful W
formation at the same time that the euro
dollar pair is looking quite toppy. Look
at these two weeks here. That's very
toppy, okay?
That means that this basically pushed
price up to build shorty, okay? And
then, you know, with the idea or with
the premise that the dollar index is
forming a W formation, you could say,
"Okay, at the same time that the dollar
index is going to go up, the euro dollar
pair is going to go down. Where to? The
4-hour 50 MA."
Okay? So, that's a trade
that you could take
this week when you see Bitcoin doing
nothing. Okay?
Now, uh if we go to back to Bitcoin, I
think this video is going to be kind of
like a mix of all types of markets. It's
going to be a a strange video, okay?
But if you go back to Bitcoin, it's
showing, in my opinion, resistance, you
know, for the fact that you have the
dollar index doing the W formation and
Bitcoin
is moving sideways, okay? It's not going
lower. Also, with the idea
of this 1-hour 50 MA getting tested so
many times, um I'm pretty sure that
we're going to see one push up, retrace.
Here is where you can open a long and
then continuation to the mid range.
Okay? And here you could take probably a
3%
trade, no, 2% trade dish, okay? So,
that's one idea that I have for for
Bitcoin bull.
It's not You know, you could be waiting
for days. I mean, we've been waiting a
whole day for this. We've been waiting
now more than 24 hours to see this. And
what Bitcoin did here
is basically nothing, okay? You got a
drop, then going back in, you have a
fake out, okay? More consolidation and
then in one of these you probably see
what I mean.
Okay, but that's when I take time.
That's where I do also have to look at
other markets and Forex to me
it's a good market. Now, for those that
interested in Forex
I wondered what you guys trade.
Uh well, I can tell you like
the 100% of my trades in Forex are in
this pair.
Okay? Euro versus the dollar. That's
what I usually trade in Forex, okay?
Because I like to use
this uh chart
as confluence, okay? Because when the
dollar moves up
Euro goes down. Um and vice versa, okay?
When the Euro goes up
the dollar goes down. Okay? Since it's
as simple as that. So, that's why I like
the the
um that chart. I know that some of you
might be trading
uh the pound with
um with Euro, for example.
Have you see here?
Um well, actually you got something
quite interesting here, okay? Because
you got Let's go into the 4-hour time
frame.
You got here while it's dropping
quite heavily, but it's leaving
this gap here.
Okay?
That probably needs to get retrace.
Okay? So, now the point is to try and to
understand at what moment this can get
retrace, okay? For that I would go into
lower time frame
and I would like to see
well, I mean, this looks like it might
be forming a bottom, okay? At least a
temporary bottom here.
Which is not bad at all, okay? Then I
would probably like to push a bit
higher.
Okay, maybe flip this level. And once it
flips this level, maybe that's what I
can try it a long towards this gap.
Okay? That's another area I have there
for the British pound and the euro pair.
Uh more things. Talking about gaps,
there is a gap in the SPX. Let me get
there.
Okay, uh
I think this is a chart of futures.
Let me see see here.
Yeah, where is that gap? Let me see it.
Four-hour time frame, I think it's
pretty low, okay?
There you go. This gap here.
This gap here, guys,
it probably get retraced, okay? And I
know it's quite scary
because this is a
6 or 7% bump, okay? That's what I'm
targeting now. Now, of course, you know,
this MP has been running very nicely to
the upside.
Uh it's not very far away from the
previous at the highest, okay? It's only
a 4%
lower than at the highest. Now, the
question if it's going to get there or
not.
Um for that,
I'll tell you I'm not sure. I'm looking
for a setup. I'm going to tell you what
it is now, okay? Well, right now 4,600,
you got here some resistance.
Okay? I mean, it's not very key level
cuz you also have another key level
here, okay? Let me mark it for you.
This is the level might be even more
important, okay? 4,700. So,
what I'm waiting here is a deviation
above any of these levels, okay? To
short.
This means that, you know,
we might be in a potential deviation.
That would mean that you would need to
see price coming back below this zone,
test the resistance or consolidate on
the resistance, and then here is when
you could short
towards this gap over here, okay? And of
course take some profits at the 4-hour
50 MA. That's one idea. But, if we
continue pushing higher,
okay? Then I'll be looking for a
deviation here.
Okay? I want to see the consolidation on
the resistance. Here is where I can
short, okay? So, that's what I'm looking
for the S&P.
All right, guys. Let me wrap this up.
Bitcoin is currently inside this range.
We shorted this deviation, okay? Our
position is from here
cuz there was some consolidation here in
the 1-hour time frame, okay? So, that
swing short, I'm still riding it. Of
course I've taken some profits in this
zone, okay? But, I haven't closed the
whole position because I'm still
expecting that the most likely outcome
is that Bitcoin falls off this range,
okay? And goes to the downside. All
right? Now, I want to talk in a minute
when this could happen, okay? But, first
I want to also tell you that that's what
we are looking in the bigger in the
bigger picture. And then in shorter
term, this means literally for the next
24 hours, hopefully, okay? And Bitcoin
can can make a move for all these day
traders,
including myself, okay? We're expecting
Bitcoin to hopefully
make a move up here,
test the 1-hour 50 MA as support. Also,
now that you have the confluence with
the with this quarter of the range,
okay? And then go higher to the
mid-range at least, okay? Possibly to
fill this liquidity pool
over here. Let me mark it for you.
You have one liquidity pool here, okay?
And well, you also have one up here, but
you know, at least get me this one
filled.
Uh so, that's what I'm looking for. I'm
being patient. I'm waiting for Bitcoin
to make that move. Push up, retrace,
test the 150 MA support, you can long
here,
okay? And aim higher.
Um until I don't see this push up and
the retrace, then
I'm waiting, okay? I'm waiting. I'm
watching Netflix with my swing short
running, okay? Until this happens. Then
uh I'll probably leave this swing short
continue running and then take
um
this day trade, you know, to this zone
here. All right? So, that's what I'm
looking for Bitcoin. But
if we go now into the bigger picture,
4-hour time frame,
this
fall off this range, go lower possibly,
okay? Or if I'm wrong, I'll actually
Bitcoin just
uh moves higher, okay? But we're
expecting Bitcoin to to come lower. Um
then, you know, the dollar index also
has to decide
if to um if this is a deviation here,
okay?
If this is a deviation, it's going to
come back inside and do this, or you
want to go lower, okay? I'm starting to
believe that, you know,
Bitcoin and the dollar index, and also
the S&P, that gap,
you know, they might be waiting for one
day, and that's next week. That's
Wednesday at 6:00 p.m. UTC time.
FOMC meeting interest rate decision.
They are anticipating, well, economists
are expecting a new 25 basis point hike.
Because the Fed has been, you know,
saying so. So, let's see what happens.
If they give us that 25 basis points,
then you could see maybe the dollar
going up, reclaiming this level. Maybe
you can see then Bitcoin falling off
that range. Maybe you can see the S&P
retracing that gap that we mentioned,
okay? So, keep that date in your
calendar,
next Wednesday,
26th of July
at 6:00 p.m. UTC time. Before I finish
the video and say goodbye to you guys, I
wanted to say that if you support the
content, of course, you can give a like,
a comment, uh subscribe. That's good for
the algorithm, so the video shows to
other users in YouTube. But also, of
course,
you can register with the referral link
in the description in Bitget, okay? It's
an exchange that doesn't require KYC
unless if you are in the US, uh Canada,
or Singapore, I think. Uh you get $5
bonus when you log in. Also, if you
deposit at least $100, you're going to
participate in uh the next giveaways of
the trading course. Also,
um deposit over $200 get 10% payback.
That means that you, for example,
uh deposit, let's say, $500, then you're
going to get $50 back. And of course,
you know, if if you deposit bigger
amounts, then you get bigger rewards,
okay? Bigger pay bigger paybacks. All
right. So, anyway, guys, thank you so
much for watching,
and I'll see you soon.